here's the story from the New York Post
Epstein accuser claims pedophile had sex
tapes of trump Clinton Prince Andrew and
Richard Branson new docs this is false
this is false I'm highlighting the New
York Post intentionally for the story
because while the witness did claim that
there are videos of Clinton Prince
Andrew and Branson the witness did not
say there were there were videos of
trump which is very strange that New
York Post will put that in the headline
there were two different sections let's
read the story however Jeffrey EP
accuser once claimed former president
Donald Trump allegedly had relations
with one of her unnamed friends at at je
Epstein's home on regular occasions that
is true according to the the documents
that have have come out Sarah Ransom in
a string of 2016 emails to then New York
Post columnist Moren Kellan also claimed
she has copies of the tapes Epstein had
made of some of his high-profile friends
Trump former President Bill Clinton
Prince Andrew and British business
magnet Richard Branson now again I want
to I'm going I'm going to say I'm I'm
almost completely positive based on what
I had read Trump is not included in
there being videos of this that was not
the claim quote she confided confided in
me about her casual friendship with M
with with Donald Mr Trump definitely
seemed to have a thing for her and she
told me how he kept going on how he
liked her per nipples Ransom wrote about
her friend in one email made public when
the latest batch of newly unsealed
documents dropped however they do then
go on to point out Ransom walked back
the salacious allegations in an October
23 2016 email with K writing I would
like to retract everything I have said
to you and walk away from them
she added that only bad things and pain
for my family would come from going
public in 2019 Ransom admitted in a New
Yorker article she invented the tapes to
draw attention to Epstein's Behavior
Trump adviser Steven Chun said in a
statement Monday these baseless
accusations have been fully retracted
because they are simply false and have
no merit Clinton's rep Angel Urena
declined to comment Monday a Virginia
group spokesman spokesperson told the
post in a New Yorker report published in
2019 Ransom admitted she had invented
the tapes we can confirmed that Sarah
ransom's claims are baseless and
unfounded Ransom who has been living
abroad since 2017 and now living in
London never produced the alleged tapes
she didn't immediately return a request
for comment Monday the emails were filed
in a since settled defamation lawsuit
that epon accuser Virginia je fre AKA
Virginia Roberts had brought against the
sios Madam gilain Maxwell now the first
thing I want to say is they do seem wild
the allegations outright they do not
seem very credible like my friends got
these tapes I swear they exist oh man
you better believe it Donald Trump said
per nipples and it's just like Ah that's
that's tough to believe man innocent
till proven guilty on all all counts now
I will say a few things however in the
documents EP claims to be found with
friends with Bill Clinton he says
Clinton likes him young allegedly in
some of these documents Bill Clinton
went to vty fair to try to shut down
this uh this reporting additionally the
witness statement isn't just that there
were videotapes of of uh Clinton uh uh
Branson and Andrews I'm sorry prince
Andrew but that that additionally some
uh FBI potentially working on Hillary
Clinton's behalf went to her went to her
friend and told her to basically shut up
and throw it all away and apparently got
some kind of settlement to cover it up
because Hillary Clinton wanted to be
president when someone then comes out a
few years later and says my family only
pain for my family and bad things would
come from going public it it's it's hard
to say there's any there's anything to
we we can do here to be completely
honest it's it's almost a moot point
because it's like you make accusations
and youant them what can we really say
about you but I will add I don't trust
Bill
Clinton I think we all have good idea of
what Epstein was doing we want to know
who's on those client lists we know
who's flying on these planes Not only
was Donald Trump accused but also in
other documents one witness said Trump
was not there and did not engage in this
Behavior which again throws this
witness's credibility into question but
I will say take it all with a grain of
salt believe believe what you what you
want to believe we don't have anything
definitely definitively proven but but I
want to add Jean Luke
berell he ended himself in prison mhm
Jeffrey Epstein ended himself and then
I'll add to both of those so they report
allegedly now when you have stories like
that I'm not surprised a witness who
made these kind of accusations against
the clintons is now like ah I I'm sorry
I made it up leave leave me alone I'm
out especially real quick sorry if it
were if they were initially true that a
friend claimed to have these things it's
here say to begin with and that the FBI
or some tried to pay her off maybe
someone pretended to be FBI who knows
then it's possible when this person came
out and said all of these things are
true my friend said this her friend then
went I got paid I'll never I'll never
admit it I'll never give you the tapes I
think it's very possible that there are
tapes I mean that's how a Honeypot
operation Works where if you want to
Blackmail somebody you have them sleep
with a kid or something and you film and
I mean I know that sounds far-fetched
but we know that Bill Clinton is with
mon kinsky who is an intern at the time
so he obviously likes youngish type
girls so I don't know I think there's a
lot of smoke and there's a lot of smoke
how was Lins get the time I like 24 I
think I believe she was 25 26 Still I
mean that's you know relatively young
and so I think he does have a sexual
proclivity to like you know younger he
was 22 Yeah 22 and he was what 58 or
something like that I think he was yeah
yeah so I mean that's a pretty big age
no no no he was 49 49 so he's even a
little younger but still I I mean he's
fingerbanging mon Linsky with a cigar in
the White House well that that's an
incorrect statement a cigar banging
excuse me let me let me keep it little
family finally I'm sorry for YouTube but
if he's going to do that then we know
he's a pervert so the idea that he's on
a private island with Jeffrey Epstein
and the fact that if Jeffrey Epstein was
smart you would film Bill Clinton doing
that so you'd have leverage I mean I
think that's the whole point of his
operation and and listen I don't know if
this is true but there's some rumors I
just saw Alan dtz was getting pressed on
whether um Epstein was a mad agent I
don't know if that's true but I think
it's very weird have you ever heard that
you know but but G Maxwell's dad you
know uh ended up dying on a boat they
say that he worked for mad so I don't
know there's just a lot of weird
connections with this that are very high
high R I think when it comes to the Mad
stuff I'm kind of like sure let's get
some evidence and on top of that if
someone came to me and said Epstein was
working with mad the CIA MI6 or whatever
I'd be like yeah okay probably I mean
look imagine like I I wonder the
possibility Epstein the whole thing was
not that Epstein himself was the villain
but this was the play of high high Prof
like high high power High powerered
Intelligence agencies who said we want
to control powerful individuals and
world leaders so what do they do they
recruit Epstein who for some reason goes
from who was like a high school teacher
to all of a sudden being worth you know
half a billion dollars and they say
here's the play you get these men to do
these things we get the we get the video
what if the blackmail was actually
government intelligence agency blackmail
so when people say Massad I'm like sure
but what about any other intelligence
agency
yeah definitely I mean my point with
this is whether it's mad whether it's
CIA who knows uh all I know is that
people are going to dismiss all of those
accusations is crazy obviously the point
of mad uh with the case of mad they're
going to say it's anti-semitic to allege
something like that but the reality is
none of this is off the table because
none of this is crazy we're talking
about a billionaire who had an Island
full of underage children who he was sex
trafficking and we know this was
happening and we know world leaders were
going there the idea that anything is
off the table here with respect to
discussion or that there's some
conspiracy theory here that's too
farfetched to believe based on the
things we know happened is ridiculous
this is an insane situation and if you
told people that this happened five even
10 years ago they would brush you off as
being completely insane so for people to
know that this happened then for people
to know that this guy quote unquote
killed himself in jail while the guards
were asleep and the security cameras
happened malfunction and somehow hung
himself with toilet paper and go okay
yeah so so we know we were basically
lied to about everything and our leaders
were in on this to some extent but that
see the idea that CIA or mad or any of
these organizations in it that's just
far-fetched and crazy have you seen the
the video like someone made a computer
generated model of how Epstein allegedly
jumping off the
topk he's he's laying with his legs
folded underneath him so like he's doing
like a cannonball kind of but not but
like okay so here imagine this uh uh
kneel down
on your knees and then sit on your on
your heels and then lay as far back as
you can then spread your legs grab your
feet and launch yourself off of a bed
the video is absolutely ridiculous
because the bed was not high enough and
so someone posted a video but like first
I saw the official report of like
explaining how he did it then someone
was like here's what it looks like in a
video and I'm like this is the stupidest
thing I have ever seen okay but maybe I
guess at the same time the guards fell
asleep and the camera stopped working
yep yeah nobody believes that yeah no
it's ridiculous and I I want to flag one
more thing here just because you already
know what the response from certain
organizations to this will be but like
if thinking that mad is up to something
Sketcher has done anything wrong as
anti-semitic that means believing that
the CIA or FBI or any American
organization being up to something bad
somehow means that you hate Americans or
the United States in general but I think
that's what they want right I mean yeah
they don't want you to be able to
criticize any of these intelligence
agenes and all the intelligence agencies
came from a time when there was higher
trust in federal government and we have
shifted so far away from that it's
really you know not to be mean to the
Boomers but it's really an older
generation that looks at you and says
but they would never it's the younger
generation that is like we grew up in
the reality where you can actually prove
a lot of this stuff instead of the
narrative being controlled by the
government and sort of a a Clos Circuit
of media organizations there are there's
so much more uh independent journalism
that sort of calls attention to these
things so it's it's really your
grandparents your parents maybe that are
are saying you you can't criticize the
federal government because they're here
to help us like like no one our age
actually believes that I think on either
side of the political aisle really and
well not and not only is it things that
we can prove as Outsiders that they've
done which are horrible but they've
admitted to things that are just
absolutely Unthinkable people are
pointing out I think rightly so if there
were tapes of trump these would have
been released in
2016 this is like the most investigated
man on the entire planet you're telling
me this wouldn't have come up sooner
yeah 2016 before before the election
like here's a video I mean they claim
this they claim there a p tape of trump
never been produced my favorite Trump
legation was the somewhere something may
have happened with Trump in an elevator
but who knows what and when and we
haven't found the video you remember
that one about Tom Arnold had a show
looking for the tapes of him saying the
n-word you remember that supposedly he
said the n-word on The Apprentice and
there was a whole show on Vice of Tom
Arnold yes you guys didn't see this
watched like hours and hours of The
Apprentice it was like kind of like a
fake documentary where he was like yeah
like he was like going to the producers
or the sound guy the sound engineer that
worked on the show trying to find it
yeah if this if if Donald Trump was with
a child on ep's Island that would
probably be out but I still I don't put
Donald Trump and Bill Clinton on the
same boat I think one is worse than the
other have you guys watched the new
season of It's Always Sunny I I watched
most of the one of the episodes they
find out that Frank was hanging out on
the island onen and they were like you
went into the like for snorkeling I
didn't know anything about the kid stuff
well you know there are some celebrities
that went there that didn't know but
what would you say that the breakdown is
what do you think the breakdown is if
they knew I feel like if you were going
there you're incle
I mean here's here's here's how the
scenario reportedly or allegedly plays
out some dude who's like wealthy and
Powerful gets invited to fly on his
plane because like let's say you're in
New York you meet him at a conference
and then he goes hey we're going to be
flying down to a my private jet to to to
the Keys you got a weekend you want to
come hang out we'll we'll hang out we'll
have coconuts and they're like wow that
sounds great they go on this plane and
then a young woman comes out and he's
like oh meet this young woman the young
woman then entices is the guy ah you
know but she's being trafficked she's
being pressured to do this and made to
do this by Epstein the rich powerful
dude doesn't realize what's going on EP
films it and then as soon as the plane
lands he puts his hand on his shoulder
and says she's underage we filmed It All
We own you now that's allegedly how it
how it plays out well Alex Jones said
this exact scenario years ago he was
like these guys are on planes having sex
with children and you're like yeah right
the kids stuff those guys no question
they know but in terms of the capturing
and and like celebrities and tricking
them it's like you get a girl who's 16
you claim she's 18 then the celebity
drunk stupid and on drugs and you got
them I mean these are aoral people to
begin with don't get me wrong these
people are like I'm going to go party on
a plane and you know everybody know
knows what his plane was called
everybody knew what he was doing back in
like 2008 2010 well have you seen the
memes where it says Stephen Hawking
would like to have undressed dwarves do
complicated math problems that's like
they couldn't reach on the chalkboard I
did see that I think that's fake but
that's what they said is one of his
sexualties that was a joke he to see I
think that has to be a joke but stepen
Hawking was on the plane went to the
island supposedly I think that he had to
build him some sort of special a
wheelchair ramp or dock or some sort of
way to get him on a boat so I me a
compliance yeah no seriously they had to
build something so I I mean do you think
Stephen Hawking knew that he was doing I
mean this is all alleged you know I mean
that's interesting Hawking went to the
island is that is that is that that's
what they say yeah I don't know is that
true or is it I I mean I think it's
pretty true whatever they News Guard
rating not good look if if if someone
asked me to take $100 and put it on
Hawking knew or didn't know he knew I'm
just going to I'm just going to bet
every time that anybody who flew on his
plane and went to his let's say this
anybody who went to his Island like I
really do not see a scenario where they
don't know what's going on yeah also
like isn't Stephen Hawkings supposed to
have been one of the smartest people who
ever lived and like he didn't know he
knew nothing of what everything was up
to and FOC science he had no he's on the
plane and he's like I can theorize about
black Oles but I didn't see anything
wink wink Jeffrey yeah yeah no I think
ultimately if you were going to the
island Jeffrey Epstein wanted you to see
what was going on there which means
either you were okay with it or maybe it
is entament I think it's the plane
starts to be like maybe he was like oh
I'm a billionaire I'll get you feeling
comfortable with me whatever I could see
a couple scenarios like people who are
photographed with him at parties right
like you may not know who he is it's
circumstantial at best but the island is
somewhere and any of his other
properties he had that that big one in
Arizona
you know if he's taking you to his
private properties where he is keeping
young women that seems like he wants you
to see but here's another
scenario Epstein you know says hey you
know want to come hang out on my Island
we're going to go jet ski and snorkel
it's going to be fun you land you get
out let let's say you get on the plane
and and some young girl comes out oh I'm
married I can't do it goes okay the
plane lands and then you see what's
going on he then turns to you and says
we'll kill you if you tell anybody and
if you you don't tell anybody you're a
complicit welcome to being an accomplice
e even if the people refused it's
basically your choice of go up against
Epstein and Bill Clinton and all these
other high-profile people who are
involved so what are you going to do you
going to report him good luck how do you
like this is the question with what Joe
Biden is doing on the southern border
who do you report Joe Biden to is there
a superior Authority in law enforcement
who can stop the bid Administration from
facilitating these crimes on the
southern border
that's it mhm he's the
commander-in-chief so if you fly in this
plane you know Bill Clinton's been on
you know that Clinton is friends with
this guy and then he says who are you
going to tell Bill Clinton's my buddy
the Secret Service knows exactly what
he's doing good luck well there's nobody
you can Best Buds and he makes a t-shirt
there there's nobody you can tell don't
compare them to us don't compare them to
Luke to my best buddy luk just occurred
to me that possibly no but Tim you made
one of the biggest connections and
what's happening at the southern border
you know whether you want to say it's
like the great replacement Theory but a
lot of it I'm telling you and I'm not
saying this is some right-wing
conspiracy theorist sex trafficking is a
huge business to the cartel it is huge
and a lot of what's happening is driven
by sex with underage kids not
necessarily just because people want to
sleep with children but also they're
more vulnerable I mean there's there's a
Litany of reasons why they use children
but it is kind of connected to epine in
a weird way that these people that are
in power do not even care that kids are
literally getting traded you know like
drugs I hate to say this but like
probably there are people in power
specifically heard Epstein had this kind
of connection and sought him out like
that's aoral a lot of you guys see Jim
Gaffigan's joke yeah he was at the
Golden Globes and he's like I can't
believe I'm here you know I'm from a
small town I'm not a
pedophile there's something to be said
for what you just mentioned Alex about
the fact that there is a lot of
trafficking that takes place here and
not only is it the case that our media
does everything to turn a blind eye to
it and that elected officials
particularly on the left do everything
to have people not notice it it's that
you are actually
actively maligned and smeared if you
point that out or you say anything about
it or you want to implement any
practical measures to prevent it from
occurring so for example when border
security separates the children from the
adults that they are with in order to
vet them to make sure that they aren't
being trafficked that's separating
children from their parents and that's
just Unthinkable Dare You ex starting
with the assumption that they're the
parents even though you have no idea who
these people are and they're illegally
trespassing into your country and if you
you do anything to try to investigate
vet to make sure that those kids aren't
being trafficked you're separating
children from their parents you're a
horrible person how that's so creepy I
remember that when when you know we had
these stories and they're like they're
separating the children from the parents
and it's like some guy with a little
girl and no ID yeah and they're
supposedly do DNA tests to connect them
but how long does that take to come back
I mean that's just such BS like they
actually can tell oh this is their
biological Sun yeah right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net